puis le projet de du kennedy est un
projet que nous avons mûrement réfléchie
depuis déjà quelques années
la problématique vous l'avez compris
c'était de pouvoir réaliser la
restructuration de ce collège situé en
pleine ville sur un site relativement
et 3es
tout en faisant en accueillant les
élèves en faisant classe on a très vite
compris que c'était difficile en site
occupé de pouvoir envisager les travaux
et donc nous sommes arrivés à la
solution de déménager de transférer les
élèves vers un autre site
je constate la rentrée scolaire s'est
faite dans de bonnes conditions parce
que bon c'est jamais facile de déménager
6 ans et quelques élèves sur un sur un
nouveau site ou sur un autre site
provisoire à côté d'un collège qui
accueille déjà autant d'élèves donc ça
fait une population scolaire importante
sur un même site les transports c'est
pas toujours évident de pouvoir les
organiser
mais avec le concours de je dirais de
tout le monde et la bonne volonté des
uns et des autres à la fois de la ville
de mulhouse de la communauté d'agglo et
puis avec l'éducation nationale nous
avons réussi ce pari
qui nous préoccupaient c'est vrai je ne
cacherai qui aujourd'hui nous rassure
parce qu'il a été accompli dans de
bonnes conditions